[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d'un tamis
d'interdire je reçois l'avocat pénaliste
françois pitre saint pierre pour son
livre un pays qui voudraient rester
libre c'est sous titré chronique d'une
accoutumance sécuritaire l'artiste
plasticien hervé di rosa lui succédera
en deuxième partie son musée
international des arts modestes à cette
fête son 20e anniversaire un gros livre
vient de paraître et l'on terminera
l'émission avec bruno duhamel pour son
nouvel album de bande dessinée fausses
pistes sur la légende de l'ouest
américain qui n'est souvent qu'une
légende et l'on commence tout de suite
françois saint-pierre par l'image que
vous avez choisie pour illustrer notre
époque
la voici alors c'est quelle
manifestation exactement 7
nous sommes là le 8 mars un 2020 c'est
la journée internationale des femmes
et vous vous souvenez qu'à paris au
prétexte que la manifestation aurait
dévié de l'itinéraire autoriser enfin
déclarée en préfecture plus d'actes mans
il ya une charge de police et les vidéos
on vibrionner sur sur le net où on
voyait mais vraiment une débauche de
violence policière écoutez moi je suis
un type assez classique
j'ai été comme énormément de monde
extrêmement choqué par cette brutalité
on a vu des policiers tirer les femmes
les manifestantes dans les escaliers du
métro mais avec une violence
inacceptable
alors je crois que la population a
beaucoup réagi contre cette débauche de
violence qui manifestement était
injustifiée bon mais qu'est ce qui a
changé depuis
bah rien le préfet l'allemand qui
gouvernent les police de paris le préfet
de police de paris qui est vraiment le
premier responsable de cette stratégie
policière de matraquage dissuasif
disons les choses comme elles sont il
s'agit de dissuader
à l'origine les gilet jaune d'aller
manifester et ça se répète ça se
répercute et l'on voit systématiquement
de telles scènes le résultat c'est que
je pense que le lien de confiance entre
les gens le peuple et la police est
complètement
et terry aurait faut quand même se
souvenir qu'au lendemain des attentats
charlie-hebdo ou du bataclan et en 2015
c'est pas si vieux les gens ils
applaudissaient les policiers beau il y
avait une véritable solidarité face à
l'épreuve là le payer disloquée par une
pratique répressive qui n'a plus rien de
républicain
est ce que le ministre de l'intérieur
réagit mais non ils cautionnent
est ce que le président de la république
réagi dénonce aroui lorsqu'un producteur
de télévision s'est fait tabasser de
manière totalement scandaleuse
là franchement les limites avaient été
dépassés parce que ça avait été filmé et
qu'il était noir exactement ans a
rappelé georges floyd est bon donc nous
sommes vraiment dans une situation qui
est critique
moi je trouve que ce gouvernement
gouverne fort mal je sais très bien
qu'il a eu à faire à des épreuves
extraordinaire les gilet jaune la
pandémie des menaces de terroriste
constante bien entendu mais ces
pratiques là de violence sur la
population sur les gens sur nous n'est
pas tolérable et je crois que les
élections régionales ans ont déjà une
première réponse est bien commençons
[Musique]
françois saint pierre vous êtes l'auteur
du droit contre les démons politique
était paru chez odile jacob dont vous
étiez venu parler dans cette émission à
sa sortie un pays qui voudraient rester
libre en est le prolongement me
semble-t-il vous y raconter comment les
événements des cinq dernières années ont
conduit le pouvoir politique à réagir
par des mesures de plus en plus
restrictive pour nos libertés
oui j'ai commencé à écrire ce livre
au tout début du mouvement des gilet
jaune comment parler de liberté sans
parler des lits gérés gilet jaune de
leurs revendications de la violence des
manifestations des dérives pas très
acceptable et gilet jaune et du
matraquage n'est ce pas de ce mouvement
social bon je finis ce premier chapitre
nous sommes en pandémie est là c'est 70
millions de personnes assignées à
résidence et nous savons tous comment
les choses se sont passées le défi était
majeur bien entendu mais nous avons eu
affaire une suspension pure et simple
des libertés fondamentales causés par
cette pandémie mais une suspension de
libertés fondamentales le mouvement
social a été tué net 1
et donc j'ai développé ce thème là mais
nous accepter un seul y cette suspension
de libertés on a accepté dans une
certaine mesure moi je comme tout le
monde j'ai parfaitement respecté le
confinement les autorisations le masque
lorsque cela est devenu obligatoire
évidemment mais en même temps je
voudrais insister sur le fait que le
gouvernement a mené la politique
sécuritaire dirais-je qu'il pensait
devoir mener mais les associations
je pense à la cadrature du net
remarquable associations de défense des
droits fondamentaux sur internet les
syndicats je pense au syndicat des
journalistes et les avocats ont exercé
de très nombreux recours ce soit devant
le conseil d'état devant la courte
saison bref je rentre pas dans le détail
mais devant les grands tribunaux du pays
et ils ont eu très souvent gain de cause
donc oui nous avons tous accepté ce cet
état d'urgence sanitaire
mais pour autant en utilisant les
instances que nous offre l'état de droit
nous avons réagi et se livre en témoigne
et donc j'ai tenu une chronique c'est
important pour sortir des clichés si
vous
les bobos qui disent ah on vit en
dictature ou au contraire mais les gilet
jaune fallait bien les tabasser le
préfet l'allemand est un type formidable
je dis qu'il faut voir les choses de
près et c'est vrai surtout sur la
question du terrorisme qui est l'un des
chapitres du lit alors justement parce
que là vous avez fait un travail très
intéressant au jour le jour entre 2015
et 2020 et vous pouvez répondre à un
certain nombre de questions récurrentes
que l'on se pose auquel parfois on a les
réponses mais au fond n'était jamais les
vérifier alors est ce que les français
entre 2015 et aujourd'hui ont-ils
effectivement vous leur liberté se
restreindre alors j'ai choisi le mode de
la chronique parce qu'on est vraiment
observer les fait est qu'il se déroule
et moi j'exerce l'honorable profession
d'avocat donc je parle de là où je suis
comme disait l'ailé gauchiste
d'autrefois ah bon c'est avec ma façon
de voir pour savoir si oui ou non on a
plus ou moins de liberté bon il est
certain que la surveillance de masse
générés par l'extension extraordinaire
du numérique et d'internet est une
un sujet de préoccupation qui est
considérable il est certain que les
pratiques policières que je dénonçais
tout à leurs ennuis à la liberté de
manifester bien sûr mais en même temps
j'explique combien d'autres libertés se
sont développées notamment le droit à
l'information que vous ferez dark tide
et vous animez ici d'autres ailleurs
et en l'espace de dix ans l'extension
des libertés là est formidable
au départ je voulais justement écrire un
livre là-dessus pour savoir si on a plus
ou moins de liberté mais pas seulement
dans le domaine des libertés publiques
de la répression pénale ou policière
mais aussi pardon voyez-vous sur le
droit civil les libertés civiles des
gens là et vu que le projet de loi de
bioéthique est en cours d'être adoptée
cette année un aspect du sujet moi je
pense aux enfants naturels nés hors
mariage il ya 50 ans mais était
stigmatisé sans droits bon aujourd'hui
naturellement la société beaucoup plus
harmonieuse et respectueuse du droit des
droits civils des gens voyez vous donc
nous sommes dans une démocratie qui est
très active qui est comme une mer agitée
il ya des courants dans un sens des
courants dans un autre et je ne dirais
surtout
pas que nous avons versé dans un régime
autoritaire policiers que nous avons
régressé
moi je suis je me souviens d'une très
belle réplique de cette historienne
remarquable qui est mona ozouf et qui
avait dit je ne serai jamais dire à
personne que c'était mieux avant c'est
au nom alors face au terrorisme
islamiste dont les attentats ont en 2d
ensanglanté notre pays à partir de 2004
il y en avait eu avant mais c'est à
partir de 2015 que c'est devenu récit
récurrent à ton céder à la tentation
liberticide
alors c'est extrêmement important dans
ce livre je n'ai absolument pas minorer
les menaces terroristes le danger les
attentats je les énumère un par un pour
dire que l'état avait une responsabilité
majeure de sécurité c'est évident
françois hollande bernard cazeneuve à
l'époque en leur temps ont agi comme il
pensait devoir le faire et vous avez vu
à un moment donné ils ont été tentés par
une discrimination importante
un de refouler les binationaux du
territoire ça concerne et qui dans
certains cas d'attentât ce regain
d'attentats mais bien entendu là et au
cas où on serait rendu dans la bhl d'un
crime les républicains par la voix de
monsieur wauquiez qu'il est président et
à ce moment là disait il faut interne et
tous les fichiers sc dix mille personnes
il n'était pas le seul beaucoup l'on me
demandait mois dans le précédent livre
je me suis élevé contre cela est à
nouveau ici il faut rappeler qu'en et
fiesch vs n'ont rien fait on laisse
oubliant nbo liste pour les élections
les soupçonne de pouvoir un jour passer
à l'acte mais ils ne sont qu au beurre
nous avons donc face aux attentats
terroristes et aux menaces
une tentation que l'on voit à droite
mais pas seulement qui est de dire il
faut prendre des mesures exceptionnelles
très récemment c'était en novembre après
l'horrible attentat de la cathédrale de
nice vous ou venez monsieur estrosi
excellent maire de nice par ailleurs
monsieur ciotti qu d'un homme passionné
par ce qu'il fait on dit ça suffit pas
de droits pour les ennemis de la
république je résume leurs propos mais
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent
1 ce que l'on à ce que les fascistes
appeler un droit pénal de l'ennemi ou
alors ils veulent quoi un guantanamo
avec du waterboarding c'est à dire on
torture les gens dans des baignoires ça
suffit moi je dis que les règles
fondamentales d'un état de droit du
procès équitable ne désarme pas la
justice n'entrave pas la police bien au
contraire y abandonner ces règles là
c'est tombé dans le piège du terrorisme
nous avons en france une justice je ne
dirais pas anti terroriste une justice
qui se consacre aux affaires de
terrorisme qui est très efficace
le code pénal le colloque sur pénal le
code de la sécurité intérieure
note les juges les procureurs les juges
d'instruction les policiers de pouvoir
qui sont considérables de manière
justifiée
bon les procès d'accusés terroristes se
déroule selon les normes du procès
équitable nous avons vu le procès de
charlie hebdo le 8 septembre commence ce
procès historique de l'attentât du
bataclan il va durer plusieurs mois
ce sont des procès qui se déroule
normalement avec palabrer loi
d'exception n'y a pas de lois
d'exception n'y a pas duré populaire
seulement des juges professionnels et ça
depuis 1986 mais moi je dis que devant
ces juridictions là les procès sont
équitables et d'ailleurs personne ne le
critiquent ce que disent les avocats
mais c'est leur rôle c'est que
l'exigence de preuves et parfois moins
forte dans ces matières que dans
d'autres c'est vrai eh bien les juges
doivent veiller à ce que des preuves
suffisantes soit produite par
l'accusation et vous savez que même dans
ces procès ils ont l'obligation de
motiver par écrit les raisons des
condamnations acquittement et quand
j'entends l'autre jour monsieur
guillaume pelletier qui est tout de même
le numéro deux du parti les républicains
vouloir apparaître un à fallait faire le
buzz mais bien sûr et pour s'assortir la
plus grosse énormité du moment dira on
va réactiver une cour de sûreté de la
république celtique est 50 ans il n'y a
pas d'appel
mais quelle incompétence mais c'est
n'importe quoi vous souvenez peut-être
d'un accusé qui s'appelait abdelkader
meira le frère d'un terroriste qui a été
condamné pour complicité ou assure mme
fekter bref il a été condamné par une
cour d'assises
il est condamné en première instance il
fait appel il a été plus sévèrement
condamnés en appel que dit monsieur
pelletier de quoi parle-t-il et jeudi
que le problème c'est la démagogie
politique
entendons nous bien j'ai absolument rien
contre le parlement bien au contraire je
pense que c'est vraiment le battement de
coeur du pays
il faut que ce soit dialectique mais
dire des choses pareilles vraiment c'est
laisser penser aux gens une bonne loi
d'exception mais les gens le poteau et
pendant leur tire dessus ça va régler le
problème c'est faux et c'est la même
chose maintenant en matière de liberté
d'expression
je vous savez le problème
nous avons eu 1
une révolution de la liberté
d'expression avec les réseaux sociaux
pour moi c'est aussi important que
l'invention de l'imprimerie que le
journalisme moderne sous la révolution
des réseaux sociaux facebook
ces deux milliards d'abonnés twitter ses
190 millions d'abonnés bon c'est évident
que les abus il y en a tous les jours et
la question c'est comment les réguler
moyennant quoi notre ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur darmana diabolique
je le dis en même temps de manière
admirative et attention quoi on peut pas
faire et dire n'importe quoi dit à
l'attentât terrible de ce professeur
d'histoire vous souvenez monsieur mais
la bêtise reparler c'est la faute aux
réseaux sociaux
c'est non les réseaux sociaux existent
c'est une liberté extraordinaire donné
aux gens de communiquer entre eux
d'entreprendre de s'informer les rendre
responsable d'un attentat c'est
n'importe quoi
donc je dis ici que sous couvert de
lutte contre le terrorisme
ces notes liberté d'expression
d'information et donc de penser qui est
en jeu il faut que nous puissions
continuer de nous exprimer correctement
je termine en vous disant que lorsque le
ministre de la justice monsieur dupont
moretti
je le dis bien clairement dont je pense
le plus grand mal veut faire comparaître
selon ce que l'on appelle à produire de
comparution immédiate devant les
tribunaux correctionnels
ces arrestations menottes garde à vue on
passe chez le procureur est tout de
suite au tribunal pour une peine de
prison ferme
si depuis que la république existe il
n'ya pas de procès de cette sorte pour
les hauteurs de dîners d'expression
aussi infâme les propos soit il n'est ce
pas c'est pour une bonne raison
ce que fait ce gouvernement s'est brisé
la très grande loi sur la presse de 1881
et vous verrez que si ça parce que si
des personnes sont incarcérées arrêtées
pour des délits d'expression
c'est notre liberté d'expression à nous
tous qui sera impacté pourquoi parce que
nous serons inhibés même si nous tenons
des propos parfaitement correcte mais
moi j'assume les attaques que je porte
contre ce gouvernement je dis que ces
procédures répressives coercitives en
matière de liberté d'expression sont une
très très graves menaces qui pèsent sur
notre démocratie
françois saint pierre le mouvement des
gilets jaunes vous en parlez aussi dans
votre livre
at il vu véritablement notre droit de
manifester se restreindre je n'ai je dis
là effectivement pas dans les intentions
du gouvernement parce que tous les
gouvernements ont des intentions
liberticide
en tout cas en paroles très souvent ne
serait ce que parce que leurs électeurs
sont contents de les entendre mais
est-ce que ça se produit en vrai alors
moi je pense que c'est très difficile de
mesurer combien de français ou d'autres
personnes ont été dissuadés d'aller
manifester parce qu'on a reproché un
mais oui personne ne peut les compter
bon en revanche lorsqu'on voit les
images de ces violences là lorsque l'on
se rend compte que au moment dé gilet
jaune à peu près 30 manifestants ont été
soit perdu un oeil
soit amputé d'une main pour avoir
ramassé une grenade c'était tout sauf
une bonne idée c'est une évidence mais
ce sont des moyens totalement
disproportionnée je dis qu'il est
totalement anormal que dans notre pays
des manifestants
même dans ce contexte perdre une main
c'est intolérable
eh bien je pense que ça a eu un effet
dissuasif et les gardes à vue préventive
alors ça fait partie du panel ça a été
discuté de quoi s'agit-il précisément
lors des manifestations des gilet jaune
de très nombreux manifestants ont été
arrêtés avant les manifestations
contrôlé au motif qu'ils avaient un
gilet jaune ou quelque chose dans leur
voiture placé en garde à vue
donc déjà nous sommes là dans le
préventif mais le plus grave a été
qu'ils ont été maintenues en garde à vue
du samedi matin au dimanche soir
la fin des manifestants empêchaient
manifeste et oui alors le procureur de
la république à assumer cela d'une
certaine façon il a expliqué que c'était
une manière de les empêcher de retourner
manifester là où des infractions des
violences continuaient d'être commise
moi je pense qu'il s'agit d'une
extension du code de procédure pénale be
bien bien hasardeuse et je pense que la
pratique s'est arrêtée en fait avec les
manifestations de gilet jaune
je pense que vraiment on ne joue pas
avec la justice pénale et c'est pas
possible d'interpréter de cette façon là
les textes ce qui est préoccupant
surtout c'est que finalement quand nous
les avocats ont dénoncé un excès de
pouvoir du procureur des policiers
qu'est ce qu'on fait on demande au
tribunal de le juger et le tribunal nous
donne raison ou nous donne tort on va en
appel en cassation c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne
là rien pourquoi parce que les
manifestants ont été relâchés ils n'ont
pas eu procès rien du tout et donc c'est
très difficile ensuite de leur expliquer
vous savez on va faire un procès contre
l'état et ça va durer 3 ans etc
les gens ils renoncent si vous voulez
donc cette pratique de garde à vue
préventive finalement n'a pas été jugée
excessive alors qu'à mon sens elle l'est
et avec la pandémie qu'ovide 19 on a
connu après l'état d'urgence liées aux
attentats
on a connu l'état d'urgence sanitaire
qui était sans précédent 1 et on là je
le disais tout à l'heure on l'a accepté
mais ledit gouvernement à disposer d'un
pouvoir absolument sans précédent aucun
gouvernement aucune dictature dans
l'histoire n'avait disposé d'autant de
pouvoir et notamment ce pouvoir
invraisemblable de nous empêcher de
sortir alors pour de bonnes raisons
c'est bien pour ça qu'on l'a accepté
d'ailleurs enfin c'était quand même
quelque chose de très particulier
est ce qu'il en reste quelque chose
aujourd'hui est ce que dans les textes
on peut plus facilement qu'avant nous
empêcher d'être libres tout simplement
c'est pour ça que j'ai rédigé ce livre
sous la forme d'une chronique parce que
je me suis dit on a vécu quelque chose
de tellement sidérant
au sens propre du terme que des claviers
va reprendre on va l'oublier
1 donc j'ai tenu à raconter au jour le
jour ce qui s'est passé et
je me suis rendu compte que au tout
début il y avait un vague texte du code
de la santé publique qui disait que le
ministre de la santé peut prendre toutes
les mesures utiles si un problème de
d'épidémie ouais un peu court donc très
rapidement le gouvernement a fait voter
par le parlement une loi un peu plus
détaillée mais à chaque fois on a vu que
à une mesure dans la pratique elle était
comment dire exercé enfin appliquer de
manière extrêmement abusive je prends un
exemple je regarde beaucoup la presse
évidemment c'est mon métier d'avocat de
regard la presse pour analyser les
choses et je suis tombé sur nice matin
sur une vidéo qui m'a mais effrayé nous
étions la première période de
confinement cr interdiction de sortir
chez soi sauf alors y'a pas de masque à
l'époque parce que vous souvenez madame
ndiaye il disait je sais même pas
comment le mettre ça sert à rien très
bien et donc c'est l'heure de sortie
d'un père de famille place masséna à
nice il avec ses deux bambins de 6 et 4
ans et tout d'un coup un drone arrive
qu'il eut braille dessus arrêtez vous
immédiatement jusqu'à ce que les
policiers municipaux viennent vous
contrôlez lesquels arrivent le monsieur
avait soit son auto attestation en bonne
et due forme électrique déjà y verront
de toute façon loto thé comme la ville
de nice étaient ravis de cette
innovation moderne tellement france 3
régions étaient là pour filmer demande
au monsieur alors qu'est ce qu'on avait
pensé et il dit deux choses très
intéressantes il dit j'ai été
extrêmement choqué mais bon je comprends
c'est la servitude volontaire si vous
voulez et moi je me dis mais ses deux
enfants là mais quelques l impact sur le
psychisme que ce robot mécanisée alors
ça c'est extrêmement important parce que
c'est pour répondre à votre question oui
à une pandémie c'est un problème qui est
majeure oui le gouvernement prend des
mesures qui sont des mesures de sécurité
de lutte contre la pandémie
mais on a tout de suite des mesures qui
sont totalement délirante et cette
histoire de drones en est la meilleure
démonstration au même moment tenez vous
bien le ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
castaner à l'époque a passé commande de
650 drones de surveillance policière 650
ça veut dire que vous êtes partout dans
les rues dans les banlieues vous avez
des drones qui vous contrôler et moi je
dis que cette genre de mesures un impact
majeur sur notre
santé mentale public on devient dingue à
être espionnés par des robots alors là
vous voyez comment ça marche
cette association la cadrature du net de
moi je suis admiratif un à exercer un
recours au tribunal contre cette
pratique de drones perdu au tribunal en
premier instance font un recours devant
le conseil d'état et il a le conseil
d'état dit c'est interdit voyez le
conseil d'état il a été critiqué sur
d'autres sujets mais là il a pris ses
responsabilités
le ministre de l'intérieur a fait voter
une loi pour dire mais si les drones
c'est très bien le parlement a voté le
parti lrm est un parti qui valide ce que
veut le gouvernement est bien le conseil
constitutionnel a dit c'est hors de
question pas de drone sauf pour les eaux
et forêts la sécurité civile pour les
incendies mais la police ne peut pas
espionné avec des caméras la vie privée
des gens ce que font les gens dans la
rue ça n'est pas possible je pense
franchement que ce gouvernement est
obnubilé par la sécurité mais les
français aussi à un sondage récent a
montré que c'était une des sourds et une
des problématiques que mes jeux plus
importante pour les français en vue des
présidentielles et on a vu l'inflation
de déclarations sécuritaires de la part
de douche le personnel politique jeu ça
laisse de graves et quand un
gouvernement n'a que le mot à sécurité à
la bouche et qui s'illustre par des
faits divers tragiques bien entendu la
population adhère le gouvernement il
n'est pas là par démagogie pour accabler
une population de mesure privative de
liberté
j'ai lu récemment un très bon livre de
stefan zweig
cet écrivain autrichien remarquable qui
s'est suicidé à la veille de la guerre
eh bien il a écrit les petites
biographies lacets cicéron il raconte
cicéron sous la dictature de césar hélas
cette phrase formidable qui lui prête
l'idée même de liberté avait disparu
c'est ça notre danger voilà à force de
se dire voyez les trois lois
emblématiques de ce gouvernement
sécurité globale ouais tout un programme
confiance dans la justice
personnellement pas trop 1 et contre le
séparatisme
encore un mot poison voyez ces lois dans
aucune d'elle
le mot liberté n'est écrit et ça c'est
un symptôme qui ne trompent pas
ce que est ce que la laïcité pour vous a
pâti de la loi de séparatisme au sens où
la laïcité études loi de tolérance et de
liberté religieuse est ce qu'on est
moins tolérants et moins libre
religieusement ne puisse être loin alors
dans ce livre j'y consacre de nombreux
passages et qui sont des exemples que je
donne de ce que la cour européenne a
décidé de ce que la cour de cassation
décide de ce qui se passe dans les
tribunaux et les cas de figure sont très
variées vous avez vu là hier avant-hier
une personne qui tenait un bureau de
vote avec un voile ça fait débat mais là
je me situe comme avocat que dit le
droit
je dis qu'effectivement c'est un sujet
sur ce point précis parce qu'elle est la
déléguée du maire et un maire n'a pas
affiché sa religion par un élément
vestimentaire bon pour autant je me
souviens je le redis dans ce livre que
les maires de la côte d'azur
nous étions à l'été 2016 s'étaient
concertés pour prendre un arrêté anti
burqini sur les plages de la côte d'azur
pardon mais sa visée qui là aussi j'ai
vu des reportages notamment sur le site
de nice-matin décidément très instructif
à cet égard ou les municipaux virait des
familles d'origine maghrébine de
religion musulmane s'étaient pas tant de
la plage publique
même quand elle ne portait pas de
burkini avec le voile parce que
justement l'arrêté disait pas burqini
j'ai un arrêté qui dit il faut interdire
un maillot de bain c'est bizarre
remarquer monsieur jadot 2
lv a tenu ce propos ça m'a déçu passons
les arrêter disait il est interdit de
tenir des portés sur la plage des
maillots habillé je peux quand tout ça a
été re été tourné ça visait le burqini
et du coup pour l'appliquer je me
souviens visuellement là quand je vous
parle d'un policier municipal
visiblement gêné dire à une femme qui
était habillé avec un voile
veuillez quitter la plage publique jeudi
que ça c'est de la discrimination
et ça c'est la laïcité très très mal
comprise à mon sens merci françois
samray votre livre s'intitule un pays
qui voudraient rester libre il est paru
chez odile jacob ont fait une pause on
se retrouve juste après avec hervé di
rosa
[Musique]
hervé di rosa vous n'êtes pas un tri
culte aux artistes plasticiens dit on
aujourd'hui
le miam le musée international des arts
modestes que vous avez créés à cette
fête son vingtième anniversaire
on va en parler dans un instant mais
d'abord l'image que vous avez choisie
pour illustrer notre époque
alors c'est une image que comme mon ami
photographe éditeur décédé françois
lagarde a prises je pense raphaël zier
soit et 10 début des années 80 qu'il a
rencontré andré hoffmann
c'est lui qui est lui et andré hoffmann
qui est l'inventeur de les cendres et
vous êtes sûr hoffman ou albert excuses
albert qu'elle aime l'aventuré
l'inventeur du national dans les années
30 33
il a mis à partir de l'ergot de seigle
et arriver à mettre au point les les
molécules de l'acide lysergique et à la
fin des années 30 début des années 40 il
a commencé à essayer sur lui-même les
effets à ceux a notamment le faisait de
manière très méthodique très médical etc
c'était pas du tout pour s'amuser qu'il
s'entête à force de ne pas du tout comme
mme michaud d'ailleurs plus tard l'a
fait et donc de et albert hofmann je
pense aujourd'hui parce que en fait à
l'époque il essayait usd pour traiter
certaines maladies dépressive et lui
raconte qu'il a pris son dernier a signé
sa dernière dose de laisser toute petite
à 93 ans il est mort hassan ii en guinée
mort albert hofmann et haye et mort à sa
nnsa il a pris cinq fois de la cidade sa
vie et il dit que ça lui a guéri la
dépression il essayait de trouver des
molécules qui graissent un des vaisseaux
et récemment dans un magazine de france
thomas d'air france et j'ai vu qu'il y
avait toute une série de mes 2 5
chercheurs qui recherchait socialise là
et nous cette exposition psychédélices
psychédélices l'autre on veut parler de
l'art de la photo est dans l'exposition
la fauteuil dans l'exposition
c'est de ça qu'on parle aussi de tout
c'est de repousser les limites de la
conscience de repousser les limites de
ce qu'on perçoit de la perception et je
pense qu albert hofmann 1 représente ça
voilà alors commençons par parler de du
miam le grand livre du musée des arts
modestes vienne paraître à l'occasion du
20e anniversaire du miam c'est quoi les
armes desk pour vous bon alors les armes
on dira c'est compliqué vas-y compliqué
c'est très simple en fait c'est tout ce
qui est marginale et périphérie que
c'est une manière de classer des
productions objet cette pollution
plastique c'est des objets des images
qu'on peut parfois classés dans l'art
populaire mais qui aussi sont dans l'art
brut qui peuvent être même beaucoup de
deux territoires de genre de classement
et c'est toutes ses marges et ses
périphéries qui sonnent souvent mal
regardé méprisés ou pas regarder qui au
musée de la danse les arts modestes sont
revalorisés en fait sont elles
deviennent visibles vérifier musée
fièvre on essaie de les rendre visibles
en fête et de les évaluer alors juste
alors juste prix parce que voyons c'est
une des prérogatives du miam
c'est aussi cette révolution et c'est
très bien celle de l'artiste anonyme
bon on parle des figurines des objets on
a beaucoup d'eux je collectionne moi
personnellement il ya beaucoup de
figurines objets etc qui ne sont pas des
sculptures qui ne sommes pas si loin du
merchandising du marchandisage je ne
sais pas et puis tous ces objets cas une
des fans depuis un film que les fans de
plus un dessin animé ou un fast food
ils deviennent ils finissent au plus ils
finissent à la poubelle etc et donc nous
avait bernard belluc qui est le
cofondateur du mien on a collectionné
sai on essaie de faire voir les artisans
qui parce qu'au départ ce ne sont pas
des machines et qui fabrique sainte
gemme place tignes il ya de vrais
modéliste des gens qui ont des défis
firme fait des études de d'anatomie des
cahiers des charges énormes et c'est
donc ça peut pas être les artistes
modèle c'est pour ça que je dis il n'y a
pas d' artiste modeste il n'y a que des
productions et les oeuvres modeste oui
pourquoi via vous choisi ce mot modeste
c'est très beau hein c'est pas moi qui
l'ait choisie vous le savez et frédéric
c'est une petite fille pendant mon
exposition en 1900 c'est que dernière
ça fait vieux au musée revendeurs a vu
le paris qui avait fait ce lapsus ben
ammar est ce qu'on pourra revenir au
musée d'art modeste à perth l'art
moderne et quelques années après avec
mon frère quand on a créé la première
galerie de l'art modeste et puis après
la première la première boutique d'art
modeste d'abord rue du renard à paris
puis la galerie d'art modeste rue du
poitou
on le cherchait un homme et cette
expression m'a sauté au visage quoi le
et après j'ai commencé à des à partir de
là j'ai commencé à dessiner des cartes a
essayé de moi j'ai pas de formation
universitaire jeu
l'art décoratif et j'ai besoin de mes
intuitions que j'ai besoin de les mettre
sur papier et l'art modeste je l' ai
découvert ça fait trente ans que je
l'exploit à travers ses dessins de carte
qui me permettent d'avoir une vue un peu
général et qui prouve un peu ce que je
dis pas ce que ce que je dis ça pour
être du vin mais en fait on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya beaucoup de marge ou de choses
oubliées et puis surtout que le c'est
une manière de montrer que l'art actuel
doit beaucoup à la culture populaire au
fond et c'est rien c'est très avait à
lui à sion frédéric c'est très important
parce que moi au départ je voulais
exprimer dans ce musée larrey la
révélation est là et là est la
révélation peut-être le ces objets de
ces images méprisé par regarder parce
que moi j'ai puisé j'y puise encore
depuis 40 ans était une des sources de
de mon travail et j'ai l'impression mais
en fait j'ai l'impression que je suis
sûr que depuis au moins cinq ans dit à
beaucoup d'artistes contemporains pioche
énormément d'être tout ce patrimoine
mais le temps andy warhol avec ses
ressources naturelles et donc moi je
voulais qu'on qu'on refasse le tour de
tous a donné les sources pour comprendre
et tout ça nous a servi aussi parce que
l'autre prérogatives du même c'était je
voulais faire voir de l'art contemporain
le plus pointu le plus difficile le plus
expérimental le meilleur un public plus
large et un public de néophytes et c'est
vrai qu'à travers les sources de ces
artistes
si leurs sources soit des objets des
images populaires on est arrivé à
trouver des scénographies qui fonctionne
et moi j'ai retrouvé des publics
quand même qu'ils n'étaient jamais allés
qu'il avait jamais mis les pieds dans
une galerie d un musée qui se retrouvait
devant la chambre d'un petit garçon
parfois tu vois la voix ça c'est
formidable ça c'est un artiste sétois
qui s'appelle stéphane de biasca mano
qui fait que lui la pacifique que des
sous marins mais voilà il ya tellement
de 3e place
c'est un artiste contemporaine mais il a
la marge de leurs comptes à bout règle
non c'est pour ça que l'art modeste une
espèce de pays où on les refuser ou les
rejeter ou les où les haines distingue
tous les pas fini ce se rejoindre se
fédère cette action qui mine ce musée
d'art modeste il fait véritablement
partie de votre oeuvre
oui parce qu'on me dise où il n'ya pas
de peinture de toi bon c'est vrai que
des fois il y en a mais le propos c'est
que je vais pas mettre une peinture d
une tête dure vous - le mans le musée
c'est comme une oeuvre
et là je m'aperçois que la vraie oeuvre
c'est depuis venu tard j'y crois pas que
ça fait vingt ans que ça dure parfois
parce que c'est c'est très complexe
d'une structure associative liaison avec
la municipalité
c'est très complexe vu et je me suis
heureusement que j'ai une mon co
administration bénévoles oui mais ce
début ce n'était pas très bien vu un an
le milieu de l'art rappelez vous quand
on a fait les premières expositions
croisées l'art brut avaient leur
comptable pour rennes avait l'art
populaire etc
m vous étiez là j'ai pas du tout très
bien vu et je pense qu'on a amené cette
idée de traduire sa lite est entre
autres c'est à dire que la plus bonne à
moins peur aujourd'hui on l'a vu
maintenant beaubourg ouvre une salle à
l'art brut avaient la même la donation
de charles aurait été possible à 20 ans
je crois pas il y avait quand même une
et c est la rubrique pourquoi
aujourd'hui on s'y intéresse parce
qu'aussi c'est les artistes qui ont fait
si intéressé parce que ce soit martine
amarni brenner en fait peine artistes
qui qui ont collection d art brut qui en
parle qui sont influencés par la british
high tout ça fait que aujourd'hui dans
un espace d'art contemporain du musée
compte après on est obligé pourquoi j'ai
créé le miam aussi frédéric vous le
savez aussi c'est parce que je me à la
fin d'année dans les années 90 je me
suis aperçu qu'il y avait que ce que que
les musées est assez monomaniaque en
france qui avait plein d'artistes qu'on
ne voyait pas et que j'avais envie de
voir qui avait péno thématiques soit
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas faire on ne
voulait pas faire qui était peut-être un
peu difficile qui demandait alors que
nous c'est vrai on est très libre donc
on peut faire une exposition qui marche
pas très bien c'est pas très grave s'il
est expérimental et voilà on va regarder
des extraits de votre exposition
psychédélices qui se tient en ce moment
même où jusqu'en 2022
alors ça c'est des oeuvres très spécial
qui relève des arts modestes mais parce
que il ya des gradés parce que ça
voudrait dire qu'est ce que qu'est ce
que vous voyez vous derrière
psychédélices art et moi ce que je vois
c'est que déjà ces deux commissaires
barnabé bones et pascal saumade qui ont
réuni ses heures mais ça fait dix ou
quinze ans parce qu'il a des choses
vraiment inconnu des choses anonyme des
et ça va de joseph cima est dû
huit des années 30 donc on s'aperçoit
que les premières expériences avec
psychotropes ou avec méditation c'est à
dire les franchissements des portes la
perception n'ont pas attendu les états
unis timothy leary les ventes selon le
fait bien grave
et d'ailleurs le psychédélisme en
général est quand même une espèce de à
voir avec le surréalisme de l'enfant du
surréalisme pour boire quelques pas et
donc on essaye de prouver dans cette
exposition que deux que de joseph cima à
kitty picasso on a il ya vraiment une
espèce de communauté esthétique qui
s'est formée qui est spécifiquement
française et qui a à voir bien sûr avec
le même si l'équipe qu'il kiki way avait
le fumeur des fumeries d'opium et donc
c'est de cette poussée puisque
puisqu'elle parle que de grandes foules
des jefferson airplane tous les grands
concerts qui avait des affiches
extraordinaire qui était d'ailleurs
influencé par les arts déco et bien sûr
et par le surréalisme et par le
surréalisme tout ça et par la drogue am3
très bien dans l'exposition n'y a pas
que des drogués donc fait des musiques
et des lycées fermés dans l'idée du pied
de l'âne et du psychédélique que des cdc
oui c'était s'étaient déversés les
portes de la perception
alors beaucoup c'est vrai utiliser la
pharmacopée mais à rossi qui ont utilisé
la méditation
il y en a aussi qui ont étudié d'autres
formes l'esthétique cela il ya une
grande de peintures de henri cueco rick
waugh n'a jamais fumé un joint en quoi
je veux dire et pourtant son oeuvre et
psychédélique parce qu'il a il a
travaillé mais porte la perception en
fait l'ouverture vers d'autres
sentiments d'autres visions et c'est
vrai que la pharmaco perd beaucoup aidé
oui c'est sûr c'est des oeuvres et
internationaux
on se dit
expo dormirai bien avec est ce que vous
avez fait le est ce que vous avez fait
l'expérience non moi je dors qu'avec
claude viallat chez vous un homme à
femmes
c'est justement c'est pas des oeuvres
pour faire dormir c'est des oeuvres qui
interpelle guen forte
je veux dire quand même incroyable que
des des artistes comme pierre maraval
comme von karman lwen on a on a eu des
graphistes comme casa nicolas de ville
toutes ces bandes dessinées du début
d'année soit un tennis aussi qu'ils
étaient très expérimental tout ça fait
partie d'une espèce de de ne pas d'une
espèce de mouvement un vrai mouvement
esthétique spécifiquement le francophone
qui a une puissance et qui me moi qui me
je n'avais pas décelé cette puissance à
van den borre cette exposition à toutes
ces femmes ont acquis qualité un dernier
mot mais sur une autre exposition qui a
lieu elle à landerneau centre edouard
leclerc
c'est l'exposition consacrée à la
figuration libre dont vous êtes une des
grandes figures
est ce que vous l'avez vu et bien c'est
en fait c'est l'exposition qui a vu dans
la fondation à calais vaquin à
landerneau qui est maintenant au musée
de calais ah oui par douala se fait
maintenant le musée de qualité
j'essaie edouard leclerc qui à michel
edouard notre ami qui avait fait cette
exposition et c'est parce qu'elle
autorise la commissaire il a fait sa
pelle libre figuration mots ça englobe
un peu tout la figuration
de ces années là ça va de noix keith
haring qui était déjà très influencé par
la culture populaire que ce soit
françois boisrond robert combas ou
vous-même ray et keith haring et kenny
scharf ou pareil si ce n'est plus donc
c'est vrai que le miam est venu un peu
comme une espèce pas couronnement mais
c'était presque une obligation quoi je
devais je me devais un peu de rendre ce
que j'avais pris et puis aussi de faire
découvrir les choses parce que l'hôtel
je fais découvrir la comptable pour une
néophyte au ca hôtel je fais découvrir
les arts modestes et les arts populaires
aux spécialistes leur quota points des
spurs et voilà que je ne connaissais pas
des croisements comme ça il sera
intéressant mais bon je suis content
parce que les choses s'ouvre et puis
depuis que on a aussi le nouvelle
directrice françois dalle mort depuis un
an et demi
c'est vrai qu'on se professionnalise
jusqu'à présent on a fait un peu de
bricolage mais c'est ce qui nous a
permis de faire d'exposition avec
groland avec les shadoks de fer
d'expulsion
les armes sur la narco culture dans le
nord du mexique en fait on a fait 45
d'exposition glace le grand livre du
miam évoque toutes ces expositions en
exposer plus de 700 artistes
voilà c'est ça le le résultat 20 ans
bravo ben on en reparle dans dix ans
puisque chaque fois voire va être plus
vieux là je sais pas on sera peut-être à
la retraite
merci là derrière
[Musique]
c'est bruno duhamel qui succède à hervé
di rosa bruno duhamel vous publiez
fausse piste chez grand-angle à un roman
graphique sur la légende de l'ouest et
l'image que vous avez choisi pour notre
époque c'est celle ci là aussi ça fait
presque partie de la légende de l'ouest
c'est qu'elle tue ça fait franchement
partie de la légende de l'ouest où est
alors la seule chose c'est qu'en fait ce
cactus là ce qui est intéressant c'est
que cette année il a fleuri beaucoup
plus que d'habitude
ah oui donc l'image ne serait pas
exactement la même voilà elle sait plus
ce type d'image de là que j'avais en
tête c'est à dire qu'il ya eu de telles
chaleurs dans l'ouest américain l'an
dernier qu' il ya eu un stress chez la
plupart des plantes et les cactus n'ont
pas plus n'ont pas pu faire leur
floraison habituel à savoir vraiment la
fleur qui est en roue du cactus et ils
ont été obligés de réactiver d'anciennes
zones qui ne fleurisse est plus depuis
des années et ils se sont mis à fleurir
sur tout le long du tronc et je trouve l
image intéressante parce que bah elle
brasse à la fois cette idée du
réchauffement climatique et cette idée
de changement qui va être assez radicale
et qui va nous faire mal elle va être
une petite note d'optimisme à savoir
qu'il ya certaines espèces qui arrive à
s'adapter donc à nous de faire la même
chose quoi il y aura toujours des
espèces qui céda pts auront fait partie
alors fausse piste c'est l'histoire d'un
type qui depuis quinze ans incarne un
marshal fédéral une légende de l'ouest
dans la reconstitution quotidienne pour
les touristes d'une page célèbre de
l'histoire du far west la fusillade d'ok
corral entre vaille est erp et doc
holliday d'un côté et les frères clinton
de l'autre il ya une nombreux films sur
le sujet mais vous avez changé dénonce
mais pas one way up qu'interprète votre
héros son personnage s'appelle jack
white fès johnson et la petite ville de
tome stone où a eu lieu
le règlement de comptes doc et chorale
est devenue good stone alors pourquoi
vous aviez peur que l'on vous fasse un
procès j'irai pas jusqu'au procès mais
je partais du principe que j'avais envie
d'attaquer un petit peu la réputation de
d'un homme qui a existé et que je
voulais pas justement ça je voulais
attaquer la légende je voulais pas
attaquer l'homme donc donc j'ai échoué
d'ailleurs pour même doc holliday que
j'ai brèche un petit peu au passage mais
je n'avais pas envie d'attaquer les
êtres humains j'avais je ne m'y connais
pas assez parce que alors là je préfère
la jouer tout de suite je pars un peu du
principe que je suis comme un cours aux
abois avec les sept samouraïs je suis
pas du tout un spécialiste de l'ouest
j'essaye d'y faire croire mon boulot
c'est de faire croire donc donc je
n'avais pas du tout envie de m'ériger
comme détenteur de la vérité sur sur ce
duel historique et sur ses protagonistes
donc j'ai décidé d'inventer de
réinventer les protagonistes et de
réinventer la ville donc de tom stone on
est passé un mélange entre deadwood et
winston et ça a donné
enfin entre deadwood et 1 et 1 et tombe
stands et s'adonner goodstone elle à
votre héros donc qui joue lemarchal
depuis 15 ans se retrouve au chômage il
croit un peu trop à son personnage que
ça commence à être dangereux et donc ils
se retrouvent au chômage
et lui qui n'est jamais partie de cette
petite ville se retrouve à accomplir un
tour en quête tocard des plus célèbres
sites de la légende de l'ouest et c'est
là où votre album est très très
intéressant parce qu'il s'attaque
vraiment à la légende de l'ouest en tant
que les gens justement
oui le but c'était de
je voulais en fait à la fois faire du
western et parler du western et relié
l'époque du far west à l'amérique
contemporaine et pour ça il y avait le
principe de la fête news qui est très
actuelle en ce moment et qui en même
temps était déjà actuelle à l'époque de
l'ouest puisque cette fameuse légende
que tout le monde connaît que tout
tourne tout le monde à intégrer comme
une vérité elle part d'un certain nombre
de ragots de mise en scène d'
exagération des journalistes de
l'exagération des journalistes de
l'époque d'exagération des protagonistes
aussi puisqu'ils étaient les premiers en
racontant leur mémoire à en rajouter un
petit peu john johnson le fameux
mangeurs de fois on n'est même pas sûr
qu'il ait jamais mangé un x d'indiens
par contre ça lui faisait bien plaisir
que les uns d'eric roy parce que ça nous
tenait à distance de son camp
si on prend même des oeuvres très très
sérieuse comme le journal de lewis et
clark qui est la première grande
traversée des états unis d'est en ouest
par le fleuve missouri
il parle d'une tribu d'indiens gallois
qui serait originaire du pays de galles
c'était une croyance très ancré à
l'époque elle a duré des années il se
trouve que c'était une énorme fête news
déjà à l'époque mais il ya aussi dans la
mythologie du far west qui naît à cette
époque là un tissu de légende bâti sur
me semble-t-il quelques faits divers le
règlement de comptes à ok corral
véritablement eu lieu oui mais c'est sa
chérie jamais qu'un fait divers c'est à
dire que ça dure quelques secondes il ya
trois morts
ils se tirent dessus vous le rend
constitué d'ailleurs dans cet album
ils se tirent dessus trois morts de ça
on va bâtir des centaines et des
centaines de fusillades entre le bien et
le mal
les bons qui sont lemarchal et ses
adjoints face aux cowboys violent
brutaux et alcoolisé et on va imaginer
des centaines de fusillades du même
ordre
comme le seul et unique duel répertoriés
dans la grande rue avec quelqu'un c'est
je crois wild bill hickok qui se battent
en duel c'est arrivé une fois on l'a vu
dans des milliers de western
oui alors je pense que le duel des
chorales n'est pas la seule fusillade
qui a eu lieu puisque quand wyatt heure
arrive à tom stone il a déjà une solide
réputation de
de marshall dans une autre ville c'est
justement fait virer parce qu'il avait
des méthodes quelque peu expéditive non
mais bien sûr mais plusieurs médias la
radio n'a une ou deux qui ont vraiment
marqué l'inconscient et l'imaginaire de
l'époque et qui ont servi après et puis
alors qu'ils ont servi à dire tout et
son contraire c'est à dire que le
western ce qui est fantastique c'est
qu'il a toujours servi à parler du
présent il a parlé du vietnam dans les
années 70 les westerns qui se passe au
mexique par les avants tous les deux de
l'invasion américaine
en amérique du sud plus que l'histoire
de l'ouest donc c'est vraiment un thème
récurrent parce qu'il permet de tout
dire
mais billy the kid par exemple vous y
fait allusion dans cet album on en a
fait un mort le hors la loi le plus
dangereux du far west mais il a tué ma
demande que la bande à bonnot quoi ces
gens qui sont peuvent opposer comme
vraiment des sauvages d'une violence
extraordinaire c'est des agneaux à côté
de ce que l'on connaît pratiquement à la
même époque en europe
oui d'une certaine façon oui après jeu
pour le coup faudrait voir avec un
historien et fouillé un petit peu parce
que j'ai il ya dû y avoir des bandes
organisées assez assez solide et si
james qui attaquent des diligences et y
attaquent des trains mais si vous
regardez les chiffres à chaque fois
c'est beaucoup moins qu'en france ou en
angleterre
au même moment oui c'est vrai c'est vrai
mais je pense que ça ça tient aussi au
fait qu'il fallait imposer une loi et un
et une civilisation et que tous les
moyens étaient bons pour l'imposer aussi
à tel point que du côté des marches
allons retrouver quand même des têtes
dures qui s'était baladé d'un côté le
marché a ajouté celui qui aurait nommé
par le gouvernement pour deux marshals
effet la part du préfet ouais ouais
vraiment nuls au service de l'état
fédéral alors que le shérif était au
service de la ville de la ville
effectivement alors ce cas d'être très
intéressant là aussi dans votre album
c'est que vous montrez que au fond cette
légende mais c'est pareil pour les
indiens par un juste retour de balancier
les indiens qui étaient diabolisés
pendant une grande grande période
aujourd'hui sont parés de toutes les
vertus et il ya la légende de
l'autochtone très pacifique très doux
qui n'a jamais fait de mal à personne
qui s'installe à partir des années 70 80
aux etats unis alors que les indiens
eux-mêmes se battaient les uns contre
les autres étaient des immigrés eux
aussi tous n'étaient pas des natives
américains etc
oui je pense que la mauvaise conscience
américaine après à la fin des derniers
massacres 1
a fini par faire le à la fois le boulot
inverse en même temps une forme de
continuité c'est à dire que ça a été une
continuité dans l'appropriation de la
culture indienne
après s'être approprié les terres
indiennes alors que une fois qu'on avait
réussi à régler le problème de qui
occuperait l'espace
on a un petit peu réglé le problème de
savoir qui allait raconter l'histoire et
du coup par là même récupérer
tout ce qu'on avait à peu près compris
des indiens et qui était à mon avis pas
grand chose pour en faire
pour reprendre un petit peu les idées à
la mode aussi de l'époque qui venait
trousseau qui venait enfin voilà cdi be
puis aussi c'est vrai qu'il ya le fameux
discours du grand chef seattle qui a été
écrit mais il est fait allusion pendant
ce voyage en bus oui mais là ce que je
souhaite c'est un discours qu'on
retrouve partout sur un corner le chef
seattle c'est celui qui aurait dit la
terre n'appartient pas aux hommes ce
sont les hommes qui appartiennent à la
terre que grands discours écolo que tout
le monde cite abondamment et et qui
d'après ce que vous dites dans votre
album a été écrit par la cedh arrive de
télévision en 1970 est inspiré d'une
version d'un universitaire de 69 et
inspirée elle même d'une traduction plus
ou moins de l'époque fait par un
pharmacien mais qui est un prix valable
mais qu'il n'a jamais été prononcé par
le pas le chef 6ème temps on ne sait pas
ce qui a été prononcé c'est comme pour
le duel de wyatt heures qu'on ne sait
pas ce qui s'est passé on sait pas
exactement qui attire en premier a
priori serait plutôt doc holliday wyatt
heures non on ne sait pas pourquoi
oui c'est ce qui est terrible avec cette
véritable mythologie c'est qu'elle veut
à chaque fois nous montrer le bien et le
mal et que dès qu'on creuse un peu on
s'aperçoit quand c'est arrivé c'est pas
toujours arrivé tel qu'on nous le
raconte mais quand c'est arrivé on ne
sait pas exactement où elle c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ce que l'on
avait raconté mais je pense que c'est un
peu le cas dans toutes les civilisations
on regarde et on est en train d'ouvrir
les archives de l'algérie en france on
se rend bien compte que ce n'était pas
tout à fait comme ce qu'on nous avait
dit oui pourquoi personne ne croyait que
c'était le bien et le mal non cotées non
non non certes mais un moyen un peu
grandi nous je pense que
les américains ne me crois pas non plus
vous êtes chez m le voir au cinéma mais
j'ai l'impression que de ce passé
violent les ça les arrange les
américains de le la fois de le de
l'entretenir mais même de l'exporter ça
les a arrangés au fond
oui si on leur dit aujourd'hui que les
guerres indiennes ont fait beaucoup
infiniment moins de morts que les
garrigues napoléonienne ils sont très
très déçu
alors ça faudrait en parler avec un
américain mais mais je pense qu'on a le
même travers en france avec la
révolution française par exemple on en
est très fier et on n'est pas par
exemple de mort oui mais on aimerait
taxes
que ce soit remis en question et je
pense que tous les pays
je pense que tous les pays ont un peu ça
surtout les pays impérialistes
quelle morale voulu tirer de cette
histoire qu'est ce qui a déclenché
d'ailleurs envie de la raconter et au
fond qu'est-ce que vous en tirez comme
comme morale à la fin ce que j'en tire
comme morale parce que j'ai ce que je
voulais moi c'est d'avoir en fait cette
espèce de personnages qui subit une
vraie destruction de personnalités qui
du coup du point de vue de lecteurs ne
peut qu'être un futur est radicalisée et
de faire en sorte que le libre arbitre
existe et de montrer que même un
personnage qui a priori vouée à l'échec
un peut trouver sa place et il va
trouver sa place non pas dans dans la
puissance des armes à feu non pas dans
la virilité et tout mais dans sa
fragilité et dans
dans la remise en question de lui même
c'est une morale traits tirés du western
ou faux oui oui je pense que le but de
cet album là c'était à la fois de me
moquer du western et de continuer à y
croire qu' il déclic ou les techniques
l'envi graphique de dessiner ses
paysages là que vous ne connaissez pas
vous le dit dans la langue dit vous
n'êtes jamais allés unis alimentent
valait 10 dans la vallée de la mort là
c'est ce qu'on voit là c'est la vallée
de la mort non invasive canyon je les
connais via internet donc j'ai fait
beaucoup de recherches
d'image de cartes et tout mais je ne
suis jamais allée bas c'est un voyage
qui coûte cher surtout que j'aimerais le
faire d'une certaine façon il me faut au
moins six mois donc
donc ça sera quand j'aurai plus de sous
et plus de temps fausse piste c'est le
nouvel album de bruno du ml qui vient de
paraître chez grand angle merci benoît
duhamel merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
merci à vous
[Musique]